[Music]
welcome everyone to the webinar
how self-isolation affects data science
work presented by simplylearn this is
part of our teaching thursday's webinar
series we'll continue till next week
i am your host stewart creek i'm a
marketing manager
here at simply learn and my guest today
is a thought leader in data science and
analytics
ronald van loon a bit more about him in
a moment
we will also pull you several times
during the
webinar for some information
and the first question first poll
two questions what's your current job
role and another question
um given that we're all in
self-isolation how are you feeling today
thumbs up you're feeling good
in the middle or thumbs down
and it looks like we have a
kind of broad distribution of different
job roles represented today
and it's nice to see that most of you
are
feeling pretty good a few of you are in
the middle but
so far nobody's thumbs down
so with that i'd like to introduce
ronald van loon and
ronald as i mentioned is a thought
leader in data science and analytics
one of the foremost in the world um
aimed by analytica as the world's number
one
influencer in data analytics automation
and the future of the economy
regard to technology he's an author for
a number of big data and data science
websites including data flock data
science central
and he's an advisory board member here
at simply learn
welcome ronald and i'd like to start
thank you
i'd like to start off with a question
for you that's always good
okay so um
we've had maybe six weeks or more
of working remotely in most places
around the world
what challenges you've seen arise
when data science project teams are
spread out remotely
like we are now thanks for the question
before answering
thank you for for the kind introduction
and i'm glad
most of the people feel happy and let's
try all the other ones who are not
fully feeling happy we're going to make
them happy and give them some confidence
how to act and how to thrive in this new
new type of situation
and then based upon your questions and
what kind of challenges do we see
especially for for data science teams
for
for data scientists i think data
scientists they face
some kind of unique challenges and
they're not the only one and this is
let's say compounded by more general
type of challenges that
all teams in every sector are doing
dealing with and this is the result of
course of coronavirus or covet 19
we give it some different names and the
top challenges for data science teams
is really communication and
collaboration
and with a few opportunities for
collaboration and the difficulty of
sharing your work between the team
collaborates that's
i think one of the key challenges that
that we see
so far so everyone is adapting to the
new ways of communicating
and using all new software and new
environments
the seamless collaboration of being in
this same room
that's gone now and now this becomes a
real obstacle for teams that have to
face this
this new situation and for data
scientists
this challenge i think is only
intensified especially since data
science best practices are still being
determined in the wake of this
pandemic we're still looking for for the
best best practices right now also
remember that
although it's i think quite common that
data science teams they often work
remotely
they had this i think yeah this infinite
infrastructure and this environment
always to fall back on in most of the
cases and
this is no longer the case this is no
longer the norm
and with this in-person interactions
being
more or less forcibly eliminated we're
in this new type of
territory i think it's also difficult to
do more practical things replicate
experiments or recreating
your testing environment on different
platforms or
version thinking projects this makes it
even more challenging
i also think that remote works makes it
hard to monitor and to
lock your work this is really the
driving force behind
version thinking challenge and making
data science work
yeah it makes it really a hurdle right
now
so working from home also means
a lot of distractions or interruptions
you are normally used to to work in the
office and it's quite structured setting
you probably um now lack of dedicated
work space at home not everybody has
a big mansion where they can sit
wherever they want and have
one or multiple officers um if you are
at home with multiple people
and this is being recognized by many
authorities as
really a major barrier for data
scientists
teams are now working from home they
might be in different time zones
they might be on different schedules
from their other team members and they
might be dealing with their partner with
the kids with their pets they're
running around if you have to work in
your your living room
and everybody is pulling at you and ask
for
attention that's quite a personal
challenge i think that
we don't have to underestimate there's
also some operational
disruption and this is another challenge
because of the
distribution across different remote
locations this means
threat and the risk that that's
increasing
so data scientists need access to the
data
but on their other hand the securities
are then at risk and
the risk becomes very high so that's
something that needs to be managed
properly
companies trying to set their teams up
for success but
they have to implement this string and
access and security protocols to
minimize
all the risk um for any type of
fraud or any type of attack
from outside and this can impact how
data scientists perform in their jobs
how they access the data and how they
can use these specific tools
and i want to dive a little bit more
deep into the the tools for a moment so
i'm not having
efficient tools it's a big issue so to
give an example
using several different tools with
manual syncing or having to use
email to share your links to different
parts of the data science project
that have to be maybe uploaded on the
google drive it just
slows down the progress quite
significantly
and it causes a lot of frustration for
data scientists
so all these challenges they can lead to
this silo type of workflows that are
detrimental to productivity
and not only data science team but also
the companies
they work for and who are expecting the
outcomes they're expecting still the
same
on their further under business
initiatives that's something that
that is impacted as well so when
you talk about the impacts how does that
impact the roles of the different team
members
um one of the obvious things that comes
to mind is
in a hierarchy where you have a team
leader
team facilitator and now the teams are
spread out and working
more independently as individuals people
have to take some of those
duties on themselves so can you comment
on that
yeah i'm glad to see that most of the
people are happy
some are still ready to get happy
because if we look to some some research
many data scientists
are feeling more isolated they're
feeling lonely
disengaged sometimes unmotivated or
unable to switch
off from their work so their work is
always on because they're at home and
work it's all the same and if you look
to some team members
they can adopt this lone wolf or this
hero mental
mentality because of all these
distractions and frustrations and these
barriers to
to collaboration but i think there are
a few type of solution teams should
consider to overcome these type of
obstacles and one of the main
parts is trust and that's
i think pivotal for a team and pivotal
for the leaders
so that's one part and planning is
absolutely essential but on the other
hand you want to avoid this
micro managing your fellow team members
and you don't want to lose out on the
opportunities
that remote work offers as well
then the trust that your team will
complete a task
and effectively manage their time
and you don't want to set all the team
goals
in in detail you want to set the team
goals make clear expectations and do
that together
and this um you can discuss this and you
establish them with your team and you
help them
to keep everybody on the same page so
substantially this part collaboration
and communication
is is very important and team members
should also create
a system for communication and for the
project deliveries now it's all remotely
so it helps to have this solid
priorities with measurable milestones in
in the system
and it can be formal can be informal but
it can help facilitate
the completion of these this team type
of benchmarks
don't forget about having a specific
check-in schedule for each day so you
really feel as
if you go to work so in the morning for
example
and discuss your day's goals and chat
with your team members and and motivate
each other um to deliver your
your task and during this time you can
share your progress with your team
members if you're talking to them
um rather than just saying hey here's
the code
share your progress your thoughts and
take
in the opinions to cultivate that's
that's really needed for collaboration
and it's needed for brainstem
brainstorming together
as well so encourage everyone
to share thoughts and to work together
to
overcome this project type of obstacles
and try to use video to ensure the best
type of communication because
if you only do it either via chat or
verbally video also helps and gives you
a feeling of being together
and also it's if you see people on video
body language is important
if people have a phase where they
express themselves as i don't understand
um you rather want to see it because you
don't hear it anymore
yeah that's a very good point yeah there
are many tools available as well
for the teams to help to facilitate and
to maintain the communication and
maintain the workflows
and this is of course depending on the
specific needs that you have
so if you are a data science team member
and team manager
focus on your efforts on project
planning and on
cultivating a team culture and
culture of trust culture of
collaboration
and try to democratize your data sharing
and access to the project
so everybody can see who's doing what
and each other's progress which
motivates people
to do the right thing and to speed up
and share the projects and see the
overall progress
and working towards this end goal
because you do it all virtually right
now
it's also important i think to help to
drive the motivation and and keep the
team on track
and reap the benefits that remote work
brings
and there's a lot of benefits as well
you can also focus on your data
infrastructure
and centralize your data pipeline to
ensure that all the team members have
the equal access
to what's really needed to work
effectively to work efficiently
and remember that parallel working on
some
the same pipeline that requires version
data changes
to streamline the revisions or to
conflict any type of resolution
and consider also using digital
sandboxes
to encourage data exploration and the
experimentation without any negative
impact on the infrastructure
foundation as well so do this these
things
right and you have this late groundwork
for successful
and flexible approach to your workflow i
think also it's important to keep in
mind
that if you or a fellow team member
is having pain points with anything in
the work or
in the transition process try to help
them
identify it and find solutions to to
overcome it and
although remotely start really working
and thinking
as a team um so when you talk about
tools for communications and streaming
workflows
project interactions what are some of
the tools that
that you use and would recommend to
others i think
there are so many tools and that's
really find the tools that
work and that fit with your company that
fit with your team
everybody has its own preferences
everybody has its own requirements with
security
um so i just list a few but
i think it's it's just a tip of the
iceberg from the number of
tools there are and how you can work i
think the core is
structure your work try to face each
other
have a good process to communicate to
plan
this is the main these are the main
things so a few of the tools
for example zoom probably many people
are familiar with it and have
heard of it or you are in some calls
that
that you have to join zoom is this
communication platform
application that allows multiple users
to interact
really face to face and and verbally you
can dial in if you don't have a
direct connection it's an excellent tool
i think for team meetings it's an
excellent tool for
for project collaboration you can record
everything what you do so
you discuss it only once everybody gets
the recording
and they can listen to it while being at
home so it's
compared to having team meetings in in
the office which you
most of time don't record and it's quite
a benefit
from this i think it's quite easy to use
and
offers participants multiple avenues to
connect
with this virtual conference settings
and you can play with it with the green
screen as well which is something nice
and
people come up with all kinds of nice
backgrounds to give a good feeling
sitting at the beach or
sitting on the top of a skyscraper or
wherever they have some nice pictures
from which makes it fun as well
and a good thing i think it's it's not
only on your
desktop you can do it on your mobile as
well and as i said you can even dial
italian
another platform which is more
specialized is for example
is domino um i think domino's is quite
quite good quite great
it focuses on the collaboration and
gives teams really the power to work
together
and on the other hand increasing the
individual productivity as well
and this is um in addition to the fact
that it's accessible from anywhere
and you have yourself a powerful
collaborative space that keeps the team
connected
and it's working towards the same goals
all the time
then you have a tool which is called
comet and this is a tool built
specifically with
with data science teams in mind and i
think it's one of the best
features is its ability to completely
recreate
entire experiments and not just the code
and it allows team leaders to manage
users in a large distributed data data
teams and it ensures that it
that these insights are delivered to the
leaders and to the members who really
need need them this platform can help as
well to power up the data science team
who's struggling with some of the
challenges that i mentioned earlier of
planning
another familiar tool probably for most
of the people
is slack slack is
great for workflows that require less
formal collaboration and communication
and there's also quite some tools
integrating with slack which makes it
very easy to use slack as the only
interface
and connect with with some kind of tools
for example
some ibm tools that they presented
yesterday which which was great
um at ibm think 2020 and
this is designed for a more
conversational type of approach and it
shines when it comes to
id generation and real-time
informational type of
workflows and slack brings this all
these tools that you need to work and to
communicate
in in this one single platform
it's some kind of streamlined approach
that
ensures you to focus at your work i
think the disadvantage from it is
that you are disturbed all the time um
while people
yapping you and ask you or drop you a
certain message
on the other hand as you're not in the
office anymore you want to collaborate
like that
another one which i would like to
address is
a quite easy to use planning program
it's some kind of project management
application that empowers you
users to really step by step manage the
pro
projects and the workflows where you can
share it it's it's quite flexible it's
accessible
it's it's very easy to use and on one
hand for the individual
team member but also for the team itself
to keep a good overview so when you're
choosing a tool for the first time
just make sure that you understand the
needs
of both your team the needs for you
personally
and for your organization and probably
my expected most
organizations will drive the tool
selections
and they don't leave it to the
individual user so it's not always
something that you
can really control and each tool as i
mentioned has
different benefits different
disadvantages um
none of the tools have it all so you
need to have some kind of combination of
tools
and where you have your needs needs
defined
i think it must be much easier to define
what tool fits best and the best tools
bring them together and then on the
other hand is is how you use them
um cultivate the culture of this
collaboration
optimize your workflows and open the
door to each other for for all kind of
new
um new type of collaboration and
communication
which also brings probably some new ways
of working
which you're going to use in the in the
future great um
and one point on that that came up in
some of our earlier teaching thursdays
webinars is
when you're using particular sets of
tools for your work
it makes sense to choose a different set
of tools for
personal interactions outside of work
people can get
zoom fatigue if they're used to thinking
of
zoom as this is how we meet with our
colleagues
and so when you meet with your personal
friends and family you should uh
choose a different type of messaging
platform
that's the negative the positive part
what i see
i have many friends who set up a private
games all kinds of meetings
on zoom with 20 25 friends as we cannot
meet now each other
and we think hey we all use zoom anyhow
so we make the benefit of it
in the private sessions as well but
there's two
two sides of the coin i think yeah
so um what i'd like to do now is to
launch another
poll and ask people which
data science skills they currently use
whether you're in
data analytics business analytics
big data ai machine learning or
other it's kind of across the board yeah
so with that let's continue let's go to
the next one
yeah um what's your advice ronald for
maintaining work productivity
and for for making room for growth when
you're in self-isolation
yeah so um being in self-isolation you
humans they are routine they like
routine so
yeah you have your routine going to the
office um
and now you have to switch to working at
home and that can be
quite challenging i think just for your
biorhythm
but i think there are a few things that
people can keep in mind to help
alleviate the pressures and and turn
your remote work experience into
a more positive and in a more productive
one maybe than what you even had at your
office
so i said earlier that it's quite
important to
set the work schedule with your teams
but this is just
as critical as i think for each
individual to do that as well
so start with waking up at the same time
every day a single day
and maintain a strong habit of getting
out of bed and having the same routine
every day people as i said they like
routines they like habits
and this will give a boost to your
energy as
your body adjusts to to this new type of
needs
so help yourself out and and follow a
new type of schedule and start
work at the same time every day train
your mind to get into this work mode
and use that as a focus to create this
new type of routine
and remember that those um daily
team check-in meetings as i suggested as
well
um i think these these are great
um so when it's time to check in
socialize with your team a bit
don't keep it always about work do it as
if you were
together so ask people how they're doing
and be sure that you share
your experiences as well that's
important humans
are social creatures and socializing
will go a long way
in motivating yourself and also
motivating
your colleagues so
whether you work or whether it's
personal
make sure that you're always setting
some goals for yourselves while you have
your team goals
work from yourself at the goal achieving
the set self
as self-set goals that's a great
motivator
and it allows you to track your progress
so you can see how far you came along
from start basically to finish each time
you reach a goal
set a new one and keep it going and an
object in motion that
needs to stay in motion keep setting
these goals and
keep hitting them so the better you get
that planning your own goals will help a
lot and
all this boils down to pacing yourself i
think
it's it's your inner inner burning
desire
to achieve these type of goals and it's
the temptation to
always and not often is there this
temptation to always keep working
i have that myself as well too much but
you'll be much more productive and much
more valuable if you take time
to take care for yourself as well if you
burn yourself out
working and working you may create all
kinds of challenges
for your fellow team members as well so
it's very
important i think to stay healthy to
stay motivated
and especially in this time of
uncertainty if
individuals and teams can adapt to this
new approach
to work i think they'll see great
benefits that extend beyond
the current circumstances and i heard
quite some people the benefits as well
where they don't miss the traveling
don't miss
the traffic jams um and spend
much more time with the family on the
other hand yeah people miss
being together and working together and
so i
expect that the future will be some kind
of mixture
the coming the coming period once we go
back to offices um but i think the
mixture will be
more optimal and more efficient
than what we have seen in the past it's
a digital transformation
what's happening in two months what
normally
would happen in two maybe to five years
so that's i think quite interesting yeah
i did hear
a company describe the processes as
if they had been told you have a project
of moving everybody to work from home
it would have taken them 18 months to
plan it out and implement it
and when it happened they just had to do
it
and it succeeded within a couple of
weeks so
um that that does put touch on
what you'll see is long-term impacts
from this experience
on the field of data science i mean what
lessons can we learn from this
in this area of practice i think that
this
circumstance is going to have really
some significant long-term
impacts on data science in practice
as a career but also as an industry
solution
there's going to be this new data
science best practices that emerge to
promote
a more versatile type of work
environment and
it can improve the productivity and
efficiency once it initially
wants the initial hurdles of this new
type of remote
scenarios remote work scenarios once
they are removed so if everybody is
comfortable
and what you see now this lockdown is
not a few weeks it's longer
so companies really need to change the
processes and incorporate them
and that's yeah once it's incorporated
then
people are used to it and they will keep
doing
the the same thing over and over again
and yes we will go back to the office
but it will be in
in a different i think a different
frequency that we're going to see so if
we look to an example the efforts that
have been
necessary to establish better
communication and better collaboration
between the data science teams
is forced now in this remote situations
and this will carry over into some kind
of regular
work scenarios once the crisis i think
passes but once we have this
incorporated and ensures that the teams
are
better prepared and they're better
equipped for any
potential disruptive circumstances in
the future as well
but i think um what what the main thing
is
the c-level executives they're really
going to watch this closely
are taking the benefits from it what's
happening right now
and they will keep these benefits in
this new organization where they had
what you were mentioning this 18 months
to plan something now it's it's
happening and they're going to benefit
from that and now
companies are learning the value and the
necessity of this agile
infrastructure in these remote work
situations
and they're ultimately realizing that
they need to have this flexible
adaptable and accessible infrastructure
in place at all times if you don't have
it now yeah you have to
to create it which was probably you
you're quite behind if you had it
already
um yesterday as i said i i was i think
2020
ibn with more than 1 000 people they
changed in 10 days
the whole remote workforce which is
amazing for such a huge huge company so
they were prepared already if you're not
prepared probably
it's taking a lot more effort and the
skill and the speed in which
organizations have been required to
shift their employees to work from
from home i think that's unprecedented
some companies let's
like i said in 10 days some in one day
but on the other hand you see many
companies they were really
unprepared their infrastructure was not
there their hardware was not there
the security was not there while
an agile infrastructure is helping them
these companies to continue the business
during this pandemic it's also going to
be
i think beneficial beyond it and
in the future as well it's highly likely
that this remote work conditions will
continue beyond this pandemic
for many workers who have previously in
traditional office settings and it's not
only data scientist
it's every type of worker where this is
going to be
reviewed whether it worked or where it
didn't work and giving this
emerging inclusion of a gig and
freelance workers into the traditional
workforce
this agile infrastructures are going to
be even more the norm
i think for this so from the long term
companies will develop all kinds of
protocols based upon trial and error and
experience
for their daily agendas for the
communication
for the processes for the best practices
and
the outcome expectations and also how to
effectively equip the data science team
for success
in any type of circumstance wherever
they are and
yeah i think that's that's something new
and there's also some some research from
a professor at
the harvard business schools and
he has more than 20 years experience i
think in managing these disparate teams
and he has indicated that crisis is
going to lead to
more experimentation in virtual work
and a substantial expansion of the
people's
work capacities and the new skills of
development that will serve the teams
very well in in the long term and from
the data scientists
in the data science landscape that's
going to shift we will see the
continued acceleration of streaming
analytics increasing
the cloud adoption more data
democratization
we see the the further development of
data ops instead of devops more
development and advancements in natural
language processing
and these are all let's say results of
the pandemic that facilitates and
accelerate this
these circumstances i think have changed
the information flow for data scientists
as well
and the necessity of using this
efficient
collaboration tool of having operational
flexibility
and having the right data analytics
tools um
at the front and the center of the
conversation
for the for the data scientists and
moving moving forward
finally i want to add the a few of
success metrics that that will be
impacted
i think traditionally in certain
organization settings many data science
teams are measured by
activity levels and this will evolve as
remote settings will change the dynamics
of the work environment
and measurements for success will be
much more focused on
accomplishments and the benchmarks and
the milestones
these are the things that that's going
to drive your
productivity and going to to drive your
score so
be prepared to focus on deliverables
um i think that's that's the big change
that we're gonna get um
that makes sense because people won't be
able to to see
you sitting at your desk and working
they'll be able to see the results of
that process
and it won't be it's not only for data
scientists it's it's for every
every employee i think right
so as we move forward and we're going to
be coming out
hopefully of the coved lockdown era
but is it possible for data scientists
to get
hired during the lockdown or prepare
themselves
for the immediate aftermath of the
lockdown
and how would you recommend someone
improve their visibility
if they're looking to get hired or get
the
promoted yeah i think in every industry
if there's change
there's opportunities and i think that's
the same for data scientists
it looks meant feels maybe
counter-intuitive to discuss
hiring right now i'm seeing the the
the huge amount of unemployment rates
in in different regions in the u.s in
europe it is rather low but
let's say the the governments they pay
for the people right right now
um and of course there is
opportunities and some data scientists
maybe
will lose the job but i think it's one
of the few
jobs where companies will think three or
five times
before they say um we're going to fire
you because
a data scientist is still the foundation
of the future
and although it has been dropped i think
specialized data science skills are
still very much in in demand
and as particularly as business embrace
this digi technologies
like ai everybody's moving out to the
cloud everything becomes
becomes digital you need data scientists
to further help your organization to
thrive
into this this new new era
and there are also industries of course
that grow rapidly we have
industries that go down like travel like
airlines but
if you look to e-commerce if you look to
healthcare
these industries really thrive and they
need to expand
so if you think about okay
um you are now unemployed and you want
to get job
look at the industries that really
thrive that's doing well during this
pandemic and then focus
focus at these on the other hand i think
if you have industries and companies
with with deep pockets so there are have
a solid foundation of cash
and they will keep investing and will
benefit from this moment as well
to differentiate themselves from from
the competition
there's also some some surveys conducted
in partnerships with
the international institute for
analytics and they reveal the data
science teams
they have haven't seen this broad
layoffs yet so which is good and
especially
i think this is for the bigger companies
the bigger companies they really realize
we need these skills to to compete
into the future many projects
have been frozen due to due to this
pandemic
and especially probably outsourcing
teams they
they have to do other work um
and and i think there is was a slowdown
uh that the hiring of data scientists
was between 60 and 70
so that's that's substantial but still
as i said there are
opportunities um so there is
an impact right now but on the other
hand there's an opportunity and if we
look to
data scientists what should they do um
they should look to these new
opportunities
that this pandemic really
creates and perhaps consider seeking
unemployment opportunities with
companies who are working
towards fighting this covet 19 or
companies that benefit from it like this
e-commerce
as i mentioned there's numerous examples
of this both at large and at small scale
so an ai solution for example that's
being developed
in healthcare professionals to speed up
and to improve
a ct type of diagnostics to help detect
and monitor the coronavirus
and we have the research in bio
biomedics
driven by ai by machine learning to map
the virus
to pharma logical and genomic databases
and this is being done in trying to
develop a potential vaccine
in the u.s you have the white house that
has partnered with different
organizations
and academic facilities to help
accelerate research and to enhance
applications to fight the pandemic
and in many countries e-commerce vendors
they really increase
um their their revenue um and whether
tracking and then predicting of covert
19 spread
for example and developing algorithms
for that and you see
quite some projects run now by
technology vendors uh doing this as a
caritative
approach but they need data scientists
for this as well
so they those that are searching for
career opportunities
they may want to consider shift their
focus
to organizations that are in the need
for the specialized skills to
apply to discover 19 research but on the
other hand
if you're good in a certain industry
focus on that
don't don't shift too too quickly you
can also nurture
your ai and your machine learning skills
to help you
to help streamline infrastructure
migrations
to remote architectures that's something
that's in demand right now
um intelligent technology adoption
and so shift to more intelligent
communication environments so now it's
time to look at the possibilities that
arise
with this new dynamics created by by the
pandemic
and i don't mean this i think
negatively um it's it's about supporting
yourself and it's supporting your your
family and ensuring that
one was able to apply one skills in a
highly unusual circumstance so you have
to
adapt as well um and that's adapting
that's something that will help you
survive in in the future
and every company now and every person
has to adapt to the
to the new situation so i think the data
scientists in particular
they're in a highly unique position
still
to help better um to
to help our collective understanding of
this pandemic
um i think a big part of the solution
should be in
in data science versus in the the
vaccine type
of solutions and everybody who can help
in creating new solutions for this yeah
it will help
creating a better world as well
wonderful yeah i mean
as you touched on even
the the efforts to to use data science
to
evaluate existing drugs and compounds
for their efficacy as treatments
it's quite an amazing
and the potential is there and also
different type of apps with social
distancing
um where machine learning is used to in
real time detect
and and see if people are
applying the social distancing um in
i know in china they do all kind of
real-time scanning
temperature measurements so all these
type of solutions of real-time analytics
that's a big part of the solution
where we we should think about and
should work on and should invest in
next to the vaccine and whether it will
be there
in six months in 12 months or not at all
i have heard all the stories and i don't
know i'm
i don't want to judge on that part but i
think that data science
can be a big part of the solution how to
manage
these type of pandemics as well in all
kinds of small
ways to make it easier to make it
acceptable and reduce the risk of
getting sick and also
control the virus and control the spread
so
tons of opportunities and yeah
tons of discussions so what are your key
takeaways here
would you like to discuss those yeah
yeah so um
i think what's important is to remind
that all data science
data scientists who are joining us today
that the lockdown and this
self isolation has created a lot of
challenges that everyone is still
working through maybe and maybe as a
community or as a practitioner
or as a team member or as an employee
many people
are in stressful situations and it's
challenging times throughout the course
that we have to keep on
believing and and working into a
direction that
we trust that there will be an end um in
the tunnel
and be mindful of what you and your team
and your members are going through
be attentive for the personal and the
professional challenges
for yourself but also for your peers and
don't be afraid to reach out to others
if you need help it's common
if you need to change right now um ask
for help and whether it's a colleague or
a business leader and i'm sure they they
will help you so reach out
don't um sit down or be negative
go for it and don't forget to stay
informed about all the latest
trends of course in in data science um
data science remote work practices
about all kinds of reading all kinds of
industry blogs and articles
and staying connected in industry with
industry authorities on social media and
other channels
and take in the lessons that this new
experience are teaching us and apply
them
in the future for yourself and adapt to
this new situation
much of what what you can take away
from these challenges will empower you
to be
more flexible and a more valuable member
for your team so see it as an
opportunity
versus a threat so before we go on to
the
q a portion of the webinar
just one last poll and that would be
for our audience what data science
skills are you most interested in
learning
we asked you what you're currently using
but what would you like to add to your
repertoire your box of
tools and i believe you can select as
many as you like
recognizing that once we're into our new
normal
people are going to be looking for new
data science talent
so what kind of skills do you want to
bring to that and
i think it's interesting that a lot of
people are interested in
artificial intelligence machine learning
um
it seems to be one of the growth areas
of the future as well
as as you mentioned in your presentation
ronald
yeah so let's move on then to uh
questions and answers and we have some
questions
from the audience i guess
one of them is
for people who set up their
someone is asking if i work remotely
from home i've been provided with the
tools
i need i've set up my workspace
got my schedule i'm still having a
challenge
staying motivated and focused so
what should i do next yeah i think
him you're not the only one and as i
said it was good to see that most of the
people are
very positive who are in this session
and these are the proactive people
um reaching out and looking from a
positive perspective and
moving forward but you're not not alone
with this feeling there's quite some
research right now and
it's impacting quite quite some data
scientists right now
and also not only data scientists but
also remote workers
so level up the connection you have with
your peers
i think that's very important creators
team
spirit creators team members talk to
them
reach out and try to set up more time
with some open-ended team building and
don't be afraid to speak up
and to share whatever your feeling is
so it's not only about the outcomes not
only about the deliverables
it's a lot about feelings and feelings
about
being disengaged or being disconnected
you have to raise it
you can't raise it now because you're
you're in the office and most
likely others are in the same boat and
maybe don't
say it but if people raise it then it
becomes some kind of
more the new normal to discuss this type
of
feelings as well you can contact your
project manager or you can contact your
team leader if needed and and be open
about the specific areas that you're
struggling with whether it's
personal personal organization um
workplace
at home having children running around
um all different kinds of items that can
really
block you from from doing the
deliverables and many
organizations what you see now they have
employee assistance services to help
people with these type of challenges
in the transition and they should be
made also available to you
but nobody not everybody knows this that
this is available
and if i think from the other side from
the business leader perspective
please be sure that you are proactive
about
recognizing this being more available to
your teams and
your employees during this time and do
this
virtual communication via videos or at
least you can
see the expressions from the people as
well and you need to
reach out have this conferencing
everything is this
meetup meetings in in the morning or in
the evening
whether it's live better live than
pre-recorded but i think that's that's
important
and frequently as a leader share what
services are available to help
the teams with their new type of work
and work and in the different type of
circumstances
and continuously keep reminding them
because
it's very easy if you're at home to
become negative
and say hey it's not working out for me
anymore and it's hard
for your team leader or your your
colleagues to recognize this because
they don't see you
so get up ask for help
everybody is used to it and i think that
will bring you back on track
um that's good advice one
question here from somebody who's
going along the career path of data
science
once foundation knowledge is learned as
a beginner what
should the next steps be and how should
one prepare for
searching for a data science job now
that we're in the
covida era so
i'm looking for data science job we
discussed it a little bit
look where the opportunities which can
either be
the industries what are now that are
really thriving
due to this pandemic look for companies
that are good in cash and will invest
in solid infrastructure in data science
right now because they see it as a
momentum
to really differentiate from the
competition
and have more possibilities to hire
well equipped and well skilled people i
think as well
if you are really at the start you can
start as
a data analyst or as a junior data
scientist
um i think that's that's the best way to
start
and from there you can look for
all kinds of internships if you really
really start um
try to create some some project
experience
um on the other hand in in parallel
if you don't have a job you can work on
your education
doing either online degrees or
certifications
or try to think about the master in in
data science as
well um i think that's something quite
quite important and if you go to the
next level
there's a plethora of possibilities
where you can
move further as a data scientist go in
the direction of a data engineer
more focusing as a data analyst as a
machine learning engineer
esthetician
all different kind of let's say roots
where you can
select from based upon your interest
once you have
made the first career step that's very
good um
an interesting question here from a
practitioner who asks what's the effect
of coven 19
on currently deployed production
models that's a good one that that
really depends of course
in in which area but if you have
certain models if you look in the
financial world
models will not work at least partly
work
nobody expected this and nobody has
modeled in such a type of pandemic i
think
and therefore all these models need to
be
re-engineered um new data need to be
be entered and they need to be trained
again but it's really depending if
you're looking
to models from for machine and detecting
anomalies
that's nothing going to change due to
this pandemic
if you look to market trends financial
markets
um let's say supply chain analytics
forecasts in sales and nothing
um no probably none of the models
have these type of criteria in
in the model so probably most of the
models need to be adapted
and i think now it's it's the
combination of
using data but also being an
entrepreneur
and and finding the opportunities change
your
your your business and finding the new
business because
that's not something that can be found
in data
unfortunately or maybe fortunately
because this makes it
a little bit more exciting as well but
it's a good question
and i like it um i'd like to ask
interesting question
somebody asked the question how data
science will work for children at school
and i'm curious i'm not sure if that the
questioner and how data science can be
applied
in the classroom or how it can be
applied to education and as a sector
okay i'm also not sure whether they're
looking for applications for
for schools
yeah it's not clear from the question
but can you
comment on data science as it's used in
education
yeah so i think a personal
learning path analyzing
where you are supply and demand type
type of analysis
um in education let's say in the part
should data science be a part of
education
on high school or which which type of
level
yes i'm in favor is it there no um if i
look to the education and then
i'm in the netherlands where the
educational system should be
quite developed my children
still use the books and cd-roms i cannot
even
um use a cd cd rom anymore so i think
for the good thing what's happening now
in education is that they
start working remotely that they need to
present their content differently and
that
also will deliver the opportunity
for having data and analytics
getting into next next
wave into the the learning environment
from
traditional type of schools because we
can start analyzing um
who's attending um how much time they
they spend
um on their education and what kind of
results they will get
so i think that's something where data
analytics can
can benefit uh from it so yeah there's
multiple
angles and if you look let's say from
the educational part
for different industries yeah there's
an enormous shift now to going
everything on on distance and everything
in in the cloud or in the hybrid cloud
which
makes it once you have your foundation
ready makes it much
easier to access data
to provide access to data to govern your
data
and to apply models
and analytics on top of your data and
coming up with new solutions
due to this force of having
everything digitally in the cloud
much better organized than what you had
before so
as i said a few different angles it's
hard to select
the right angle because we don't know
the the right question but
hopefully one of the angles was within
the
within the range of the question great
and i hope so too
um speaking of the technology of uh
i think that's all the time we have for
questions and answers but speaking of
the technology of education
i did want to mention that right now
simply learn offers
a number of its basic courses
through a free service on our
android mobile app so i
encourage people to download the android
mobile app
currently it's not on the apple ios but
we're hoping to rectify that in the
future and
i'd like to thank you ronald
for a really great presentation today
good discussion
you're welcome um are there places that
people can
connect with you on social media yeah
i'm quite
easy um reachable and foundable
and on social media on twitter linkedin
youtube instagram and so
okay and i'd say the same thing about
simply learn we can be connected with on
facebook linkedin twitter
i'd also like to encourage people to to
return
next thursday for what
looks to be our final teaching thursdays
webinar
which will be how self-isolation
impacts a digital marketing career and
that will be with our guest
matt bailey and it'll be at the same
time
and i would like to remind people that
we will be sending
out proof of attendance certificates
the people who have stayed with us
through the end of this program
uh today and i'd like to thank you all
for being here
thank you stay safe great advice stay
safe everyone
bye-bye thanks bye-bye